A menudo jugamos a lanzar los dados. Parte del
juego es no saber qué cara va a caer, puede caer
cualquiera de ellas: la cara con el 1, el 2, el 3,
el 4, el 5 o la que tiene el 6. ¡Qué bien! Es más,
puedes ir a buscar un dado. ¡Corre, corre! Busca
uno e inténtalo. Lánzalo muchas veces e intenta
adivinar qué número va a caer. ¿Verdad que no es
sencillo saber cuál es la cara que quedará hacia
arriba? O dicho de otra manera: no podemos saber
qué número saldrá en el siguiente lanzamiento.
Pero lo que sí sabemos es que al lanzar el dado
caerá una de estas seis caras apuntando hacia
arriba, ¿cierto?; es decir, lo que sí podemos
saber es su espacio muestral. En este video
hablaremos del espacio muestral, por eso vamos a
decir que todas las caras posibles que tenemos,
es decir, la cara 1, la 2, la 3, la 4, la 5 y la
6, todas las caras posibles en las que puede caer
el dado al lanzarlo son nuestro espacio muestral.
Es decir, el espacio muestral es todo el conjunto
de posibles resultados que se puede obtener en un
evento o experimento aleatorio, y en este caso son
seis posibles resultados. Si lo escribimos como
un conjunto, tenemos que, al caer el dado, la cara
superior puede mostrar 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 o 6; y para
no escribir siempre "espacio muestral" utilizamos
como notación matemática la letra griega omega
(Ω), la anotación facilita escribir las cosas,
las hace más breves. Omega es esta letra griega
que parece una herradura de caballo y va a ser
nuestra forma de indicar espacio muestral,
es decir, cuando ponemos Ω, tenemos que leer
"espacio muestral". En este caso tenemos el
espacio muestral de un experimento aleatorio
que fue lanzar un dado y obtener un número. Este
espacio muestral es un abanico de seis posibles
resultados. ¿Cuáles son? Obtener una cara que
muestra el 1, obtener una cara que muestra el 2,
obtener una cara que muestra el 3, obtener
una cara que muestra el 4, obtener una cara
que muestre el 5 y obtener una cara que muestre
el 6. Como el espacio muestral es un conjunto,
podemos saber su cardinal. Recordemos: el cardinal
de un conjunto es el número de elementos que
tiene. ¿Cuántos elementos tenemos esta vez?
Bueno, tenemos seis, los números 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, que son los posibles resultados de lanzar el
dado. Entonces, el cardinal de este conjunto omega
será 6. Muy bien, ya sabemos qué es el espacio
muestral. ¡Genial! Así que hagamos otro ejemplo
para entender mejor este concepto. Esta vez vamos
a usar dos monedas y vamos a lanzarlas. Cada una
de ellas tiene dos opciones: por un lado, muestra
cara, y, por el otro, cruz o sello, así que ¿cómo
podemos representar el espacio muestral de lanzar
dos monedas al aire? Pausa el video y piénsalo.
Bien, trabajemos juntos. Primero recordemos que
el espacio muestral es el conjunto de todos los
posibles resultados de un experimento aleatorio,
así que, si pensamos en una sola moneda,
su espacio muestral al lanzarla es cara o
sello. ¡Venga, tú puedes lanzarla! Siempre
cae o cara o sello, no hay otra opción. Pero,
¿qué pasa cuando lanzamos dos monedas al aire?,
¿sigue siendo el mismo espacio muestral?
Venga, lanza las monedas muchas veces y anota
el resultado. Te espero. Bueno, la pregunta es:
¿sigue siendo el mismo espacio muestral?, y ya
puedes ver que la respuesta es no. Si lanzamos dos
monedas al aire, entonces tenemos las siguientes
posibilidades: podemos obtener como resultado en
la primera moneda cara o podemos obtener sello;
a partir del resultado de la primera moneda,
la segunda moneda también puede caer en cara o
puede caer en sello, y lo mismo pasa cuando la
primera moneda cae en sello, las opciones para
la segunda moneda son las mismas: puede ser o cara
o sello. Esto nos da cuatro posibles resultados:
que en la primera moneda obtengamos cara
y en la segunda también obtengamos cara,
o que en la primera moneda obtengamos cara y en
la segunda obtengamos sello, o que en la primera
moneda obtengamos sello -observa, aquí cambia
la primer moneda-, en la segunda obtengamos
cara o que la primera moneda obtengamos sello
y en la segunda también obtengamos sello. Esto
está muy interesante, y por lo tanto, podemos
representar el conjunto omega. Recuerda que
omega es nuestro espacio muestral, es decir, el
conjunto de todos los posibles resultados de un
experimento aleatorio; podemos representarlo
como Ω es igual al conjunto de: cara-cara,
cara-sello, sello-cara o sello-sello. Estos son
los cuatro posibles resultados en nuestro abanico
de posibilidades para nuestro experimento
aleatorio con monedas, y, por lo tanto,
el cardinal de este conjunto es 4. Perfecto, ahora
observa esto. Esto es muy emocionante. Observa que
al escribir todas las posibilidades de esta forma
hemos creado ¡un árbol!, un árbol con todas las
posibilidades. Esta es otra forma de representar
nuestro espacio muestral, como un árbol que tiene
todas las posibilidades, puedes ver que cada
una de estas líneas representa una rama y estos
últimos resultados representan hojas, o al menos
así se llaman. Si pensamos en el caso del dado,
también podemos representarlo como un árbol: estas
son las ramas y cada hoja representa un resultado
distinto de todos los posibles, es decir,
tenemos una hoja para el 1, otra hoja para el 2,
otra hoja para el 3, otra hoja para el 4, otra
hoja para el 5 y otra hoja para el 6. Ahora ya
sabemos que tenemos dos formas de representar
el espacio muestral de un experimento aleatorio:
con árboles o con conjuntos. Así que es todo
por este video; nos vemos en el siguiente.